cent vingt mille soldats russes massés à
la frontière avec l'ukraine
des centaines d'avions de chasse
d'hélicoptères d'assaut et des missiles
et des apports en sang en cas de
transfusion des manoeuvres qui ont
valeur de menaces pour les occidentaux
alors en coulisses la riposte se
préparent elles seraient d'abord
économiques envers une tranche bien
spécifique de la population russe nous
avons élaboré des gens semblent de
sanctions envers les élites russes et
les membres de leur famille si la russie
envahi d'avantagé crème et les individus
identifiés se trouve dans le cercle
restreint du kremlin ou à proximité
il joue un rôle dans la prise de
décision à un gouvernement on son
complice du comportement des
stabilisateurs et d'ukraine les
oligarques russes cible particulièrement
vulnérables en raison de leur liens
financiers très étroits avec les
occidentaux il s'agirait notamment de
couper l'accès des banques russes aux
transactions en dollars devise référence
des échanges internationaux même
stratégie du côté du royaume uni autre
destination privilégiée de l'élite russe
d'ascète leurs avoirs au royaume uni
seront gelés aucune entreprise ni aucun
particulier britanniques ne sera en
mesure de traiter avec eux et s'ils
cherchent à entrer au royaume uni ils
seront refoulés l'hôpital pas si moscou
a déjà promis une riposte sans donner
plus de détails pour l'instant la voie
diplomatique reste privilégiée pour
éviter une escalade des deux côtés on
use beaucoup sur le coup de fil prévue
ce mardi entre le secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken et son
homologue russe